hello you're playing the waiting game
the show that mollycoddles the crap out
of you while you're waiting for a game
to come out this week we've got a date
with destiny yes first hinted that all
the way back in Halo 3 ODST bungees
first shooter since leaving Master Chief
to his own devices destiny is starting
to loom large on the horizon Bungie have
been slightly cagey about details so far
but we do know destiny is set in a
post-apocalyptic world with mankind
teetering on the brink of extinction you
play as a guardian sworn to protect the
last City Earth has left most
interestingly destiny will be a sort of
MMO though not in the traditional sense
while your game will be connected with
loads of others across the internet you
won't be able to see absolutely everyone
only the ones the game matches you with
it's an on-the-fly matchmaking system
Bungie says we'll make the game alive I
think it makes the game confusing anyway
if you can't wait to sink your teeth
into bungees first release post halo
don't fret we've got some stuff to keep
you busy until launch day first up is
borderlands 2 probably my favorite
shooter of all time setting the
apocalyptic wasteland of Pandora you
play as one of four different vault
hunters all of you on a quest to stop
their evil handsome jack okay bits not
an MMO but with some brilliant loot
focus gameplay and some of the best
writing I've ever seen in a video game
Borderlands 2 is a hilarious romp and
well worth picking up it's good enough
by yourself but playing with a friend is
where Borderlands 2 really comes into
its own I've put over 90 hours into that
game with my friend Matt and I'd do it
again in a heartbeat if you want to get
ready to stomp around in the post
apocalypse of destiny with a bunch of
people probably stealing your kills
Borderlands 2 is a great way to get
warmed up that said while it has some
serious moments Borderlands 2 is almost
certainly a comedy what if you want an
online shooter with a bit more gravitas
well there's always dust 514 it's not
earth shatteringly brilliant but the
concept is pretty novel and most
importantly it's free to play so you're
not allowed to come after me claiming I
forced
you to piss a bunch of money away
directly impacting on the economy of EVE
Online dust 514 turns you into a capsule
ear an immortal infantry soldier
fighting for control over various
different planets there are some decent
customization options all designed to
mix things up as you run around the
various maps shooting at other people
across the internet while dust 514 did
considerably better in previews than in
the actual review stage the scale of the
game is a lot closer to what we can
expect from destiny then Borderlands 2
so you may as well give it a punt all
right then that's the game's out the way
but surely the post apocalypse has more
to offer then running around shooting
dudes it does friend Adventure Time is
simply put one of the greatest cartoons
of all time following the adventures of
Finn the human and his faithful stretchy
dog Jake the 11 minute episodes are
incisive inventive and above all
hilarious the show is also set after a
nuclear apocalypse by the way meaning
Finn is pretty much the last human alive
oh so this isn't human oh no this is soy
people oh I've never tasted real human
before but they're so you can't even
tell different references to the
mushroom war mean it's surprisingly dark
for something aimed at children but to
be honest the whole experience of
watching adventure time is so wonderful
I don't really care there's also an
official game called explore the dungeon
because i don't know but unfortunately
it sucks because there's no justice in
the world then again sonic borderlands 2
adventure time is definitely a comedy
and what if you don't want to spend the
time waiting for destiny laughing like a
drain well that's your loss if you ask
me but I've still got you covered young
people from all over the globe are
joining up to fight for the future I'm
doing my part I'm doing my part I'm
doing my part they're doing their phone
are you starship troopers is a bombastic
action film about giant bugs that
threaten human existence and the
soldiers who want to kill them what
makes Starship Troopers really stand out
though is how ahead of time it actually
was the constant information updates
thrown at the viewer are an interesting
critique on the United States and its
stance on foreign policy Starship
Troopers pretty much predicted the u.s.
reaction to 911 making it a fascinating
watch as well as a pretty decent action
film okay so at the end of the day it is
still a lot of meatheads shooting at
giant bugs but that reflective tone adds
a poignancy to starship troopers that we
can probably expect from destiny Bungie
are after all once for injecting a bit
of contemplative drama into proceedings
will watching starship troopers make you
a better destiny player no it won't well
you have fun watching it definitely
everyone's doing their part are you the
war effort needs your effort and work at
home in your community and finally just
because we don't want to be blamed for
declining literacy rates you should try
reading dune set in the distant future
June concerns itself with a series of
planets each ruled by a noble house when
the control of planet Arrakis sole
source of the incredibly valuable spice
comes up for contention all sorts of
political back and forth in gets
underway well not exactly a
post-apocalypse June is probably the
closest of this week's picks to the
setting of destiny and should give you a
decent feel for what to expect when the
game finally launches until then I'm off
but if you want to check out any of the
stuff we talked about in this episode
follow the link on screen now for a
handy amazon list feel free to make your
own recommendations in a comment or by
tweeting with the hashtag GS waiting
game see you next time
you